sorin sagt uns was heute entscheidend
ist für guten oder schlechten geschmack
was ziehen wir an was zieht uns an das
sind fragen alles andere als banal
barbara vinken ist eine die mode denkt
für sie zeigt sich in der art wie wir
uns kleiden unser verhältnis zur welt
ich denke immer dass es für alle
erfreulicher ist wenn man dieses
verhältnis angesagt und eher heiter oder
schlecht auch komisch manchmal auch
aggressiv aber wenn man das wenn man das
auf jeden fall gestaltet wenn man nicht
denkt es ist mir egal
und so ist das kleid das sie direkt zum
interview in ihrer sommerresidenz
natürlich mit bedacht gewählt
in der mode weil an dem sieger das war
ja sehr wichtig für die beiden
industrien
jedes kleidungsstück hat etwas zu
erzählen
auch über die beziehung der geschlechter
barbara vinken ist feministin einer der
bestgekleideten frauen werden solch ein
rollentausch wäre nichts neues
barbara fink blick auf sonnenkönig louis
kartons macht klar
früher galt man als das schöne
geschlecht putzte sich heraus
inszenierte seinem körper
viel bein viele roth ich erst seit der
französischen revolution fiel diese
aufgabe an die frauen ihre silhouetten
endlos lange beine bestimmen bis heute
die mode die mode wurde weiblich
und männer kleidung zur anti mode der
bürgerlichen mann hatte wichtigeres zu
tun
verschwand im anzug der beruf sony vorn
ein manifest gegen alles modische
neutralisierte die männer körper nur die
krawatte ein kleines letztes zeichen von
prof
doch seit ein paar jahren beschreibt die
mode eine zeitenwende immer weniger
männer müssen anzug tragen da erlebt der
seine wiedergeburt als modisches
statement
man zeigt wie der silhouette betont die
figuren durch schnitte aus der weibliche
note gut
interessanterweise wird daher auch
wirklich viel gearbeitet
er wird technik und der einzug ist damit
eigentlich dass keine schwache der
frauen geworden
frau darf mittlerweile auch hierzulande
an der macht seien
doch sie macht auf man teilt sich im
anzug gibt sich in der anpassung der
mimikry an den alten männer stil mehr
mut frauen
mein frau finden ich glaube es kommt
grundsätzlich darauf an diese diese
weibliche normiert zu mischen und zu
durchbrechen mit kleidung die autorität
transportiert ohne in der mimikry 1
männliche zu verfallen
für diese kompetente weiblichkeit gibt
es vorbilder mächtige frauen wie
weltbank chefin christine lagarde oder
facebook geschäftsführerin sheryl
sandberg die inmitten graue mäuse stil
zeigen
doch wie findet der mensch den mut zum
statement
wie findet man guten geschmack
was muss wissen wer im hektischen
betrieb der moden seinen stil entwickeln
will
wie viel angst muss man haben vor
schlechtem geschmack
man kann generell sein dass jede mode
wenn sie modisch wird eine geschmacks
überschreitung hin zum schlechten
geschmack mit sich bringt jedenfalls
muss sich eine prise davon haben glaube
ich auf der gratwanderung zwischen gutem
und schlechtem geschmack dürfen wir
heute fast alles tragen
doch seit der höfischen gesellschaft
zählt eines unverändert spreads adula
das heißt wir sollten uns bemühen aber
es muss mehr los war
lässig wie die natürlichste sache der
welt
was angestrengt wirkt krank nicht schön
sein
ich glaube dass ironie und selbstironie
und witz für die mode ganz entscheidend
ist auch für das eigene selbst verhält
und auch für die lust die man daran hat
er als ich glaube so was wie witz
intelligenz selbst distanz auch mal über
sich selbst lachen können in seinem
inszenierungs will dass diese sachen
vielleicht heute ist aber das
allerwichtigste
es kennt kaum regeln das modische spiel
mit dem guten geschmack was es braucht
ist nur die lust es mitzugestalten